die waffen für die ukraine das war
gestern auch großes thema bei der
generaldebatte im bundestag die ein
schlagabtausch vor allem zwischen
oppositionsführer märz und bundeskanzler
scholz war
wir haben zur erinnerung unter anderem
beschlossen
neben der humanitären und finanziellen
hilfe der ukraine auch schwere waffen zu
liefern damit dieses land sich gegen die
russische aggression ausreichend und
erfolgreich verteidigen kann muss ich
feststellen mehr als einen monat nach
dieser gemeinsamen entschließung im
deutschen bundestag sind der ukraine bis
zum heutigen tag die zugesagten waffen
nicht geliefert worden sie sind hier
durch die sache durch die tänze und
haben nichts konkretes gesagt morbid
wäre wirklich sehr vernünftig gewesen
was soll denn andere schwere waffen
seien als zb gebhard oder die
panzerhaubitze das ist doch einfach
dahergeredet es zeigt dass sie nach
vortrag und
den oppositionsführer und unions
fraktionsvorsitzenden begrüßen wir jetzt
bei uns im studio guten morgen frau
morgen frau von fürst scholz war die ja
von ihnen gewünscht zum teil zumindest
vom redemanuskript abgewichen für viele
überraschend emotional gerade zu laut
waren sie zufrieden mit dem kanzler
immerhin haben wir daher was bewirkt
naja ich habe bewirkt dass er mal
abweichen von zeiten vorbereiteten
redemanuskript gesprochen hat er hat
erneut zusagen gemacht
aber man muss es einfach so sagen
deutschland liefert nicht und
deutschland verzögert und jeden tag
sterben in diesem land menschen und zwar
in großer zahl die russische aggression
wird jeden tag härter richtet sich jetzt
mittlerweile auch gegen odessa das heißt
im klartext man hätte mehr tun müssen
ich will es mal so sagen wenn sich alle
staaten auf der welt so verhalten hätten
wie deutschland dann hätte die russische
armee kiew bereits eingenommen
zu den waffenlieferungen vielleicht
nochmals zu konkretisieren bis ende juni
mehrfach raketenwerfer zu dem eben das
moderne flugabwehrsystem das
zugegebenermaßen noch ein bisschen schon
wie angekündigt länger dauern wird aber
herr merz fakt ist ja auch die
bundeswehr ist in einem desolaten
zustand viele wissen das schon
ganz lange aber jetzt ist es quasi so
gut wie offiziell und wir können zum
teil da vielleicht gar nicht schneller
mehr liefern und da können sie auch
nicht so tun als hätte die union jetzt
nichts damit zu tun die union hat 16
jahre die kanzlerin gestellt und diverse
verteidigungsminister jetzt wo wir
trotzdem mal zwei sachverhalte
auseinanderhalten das eine ist die
bundeswehr und dafür werden wir morgen
nachmittag 100 milliarden euro
beschließen eines neuen sondervermögens
schulden um die bundeswehr wirklich
auszurüsten und aufzurüsten die frage
was wir heute am tag liefern könnten was
zum beispiel auch aus industrie
beständen geliefert werden könnte ist
eine andere frage 100 marder panzer sind
seit wochen angeboten worden zu liefern
ringtausch hat die bundesregierung
anschließend gesagt machen wir dann mit
vielen anderen staaten in europa davon
hat bis heute nicht stattgefunden
deutschland hätte der ukraine marder
panzer liefern können sie machen es
nicht sie verzögern ist die kündigung es
an sie sagen ringtausch und dem ring der
ringtausch funktioniert nicht also hier
wird ganz bewusst auf der bremse
gestanden hier wird ganz bewusst der
ukraine nicht das material geliefert was
wir übrigens auch ein großer
gemeinsamkeit am 28 april im deutschen
bundestag beschlossen haben jetzt haben
sie gerade die abstimmung morgen über
das sondervermögen angesprochen wird die
union länder geschlossen dafür stehen da
gab es durchaus ja nochmal redebedarf
mit oskar brede bedarf gestern noch
einmal wegen der sogenannten wegen des
wirtschaftsplans das heißt also der der
liste die da angefügt werden muss an das
errichtungs und finanzierungsgesetz das
ist geklärt worden das hat noch mal eine
ganze reihe von unstimmigkeiten aus dem
verteidigungsministerium gegeben dass
konnte gestern geklärt werden und
deswegen können wir morgen zustimmen
seit der bundestagswahl sind sie im
moment oppositionsführer jetzt gab es
schon mehrere landtagswahlen unter
anderem schleswig holstein und nordrhein
westfalen und da sehen wir momentan zwei
sehr erfolgreiche cdu-politiker die
ministerpräsidenten mit henrik wüst und
dann günther
beobachten wir da momentan zwei
potenzielle kanzlerkandidaten es gibt in
hessen seit vorgestern einen weiteren
sehr erfolgreichen ministerpräsidenten
boris rhein der sogar mit stimmen der
opposition im hessischen landtag gewählt
worden ist ich freue mich über jeden
erfolg eines ministerpräsidenten
hoffentlich demnächst auch mal wieder
einer ministerpräsidentin das macht die
union insgesamt stark und über alle
anderen fragen brauchen wir heute
überhaupt nicht zu diskutieren die
letzte bundestagswahl liegt gerade sechs
monate zurück die nächsten dreieinhalb
jahren morgen dann sprechen wir darüber
vielleicht noch eine weitere abstimmung
und zwar über den mindestlohn die
erhöhung auf 12 euro wir hören ihre
union will sich da enthalten obwohl da
bereits eben erwähnte hendrik wüst aus
nrw im wahlkampf noch dafür war gibt es
da uneinigkeit nein da gibt es keine
uneinigkeit da gibt es nur eine
diskussion über das verfahren wir sind
nicht gegen 12 euro mindestlohn niemand
von uns ist dagegen aber die
bundesregierung hat es nun für richtig
befunden übrigens mit der fdp zusammen
was uns sehr überrascht hat die
lohnfrage zum gegenstand von
gesetzgebung zu machen und da gehört sie
nicht hin lohnfindung in sache der
tarifvertragsparteien auf betrieblicher
ebene und auch auf über betrieblicher
ebene und deswegen reichen wir die hand
nicht dazu dass jetzt in deutschland der
gesetzgeber anfängt löhne gesetzlich
festzuschreiben auf diese rutschbahn
begeben wir uns nicht sagt der
oppositionsführer und vorsitzender der
unions-fraktion friedrich merz ganz
herzlichen dank für ihren